[Music]
the secret language of feet a few facts
for starters
during an average lifetime our feet will
walk 115 000 miles
or 185 000 kilometers
that's the equivalent to walking around
the world more than four
times each pair of feet has around 250
000 sweat glands we release up to half a
pint of sweat
every day from our feet or 100 liters in
a year
the average british foot has increased
by two uk sizes since the 1970s
we are taller and heavier in part due to
our diet
the little micro moves your feet say a
huge amount about what's going on in
your mind
studies suggest men move their feet more
when they're anxious
but women's feet stay still though they
do release a nervous energy as they
become more comfortable
men tend not to give clues about their
attraction towards a person with their
feet
but women do an open posture and foot
movement away from the body are clues of
attraction
in ancient egypt nail polish was used to
show social standing
the lower classes often wore nude and
light colours
while high society painted their nails
red
these days well it's up to you
if you think you can stop feet
communicating by covering them
think again a study from the university
of kansas
found people are able to accurately
guess age
income and a number of personality
traits
just from looking at their shoes
practical
and functional shoes tend to be worn by
agreeable people
while old but well-kept shoes suggest a
conscientious owner
researchers found the brighter the shoe
the less anxious the owner tends to be
like shoes your socks can be equally
revealing
in silicon valley and elsewhere wearing
colorful or flamboyant socks
is an acceptable shot of flair for men
in a generally gestamed culture
if your second toe is larger than the
big toe that's called
morton's toe the ancient greeks love
this shape of foot
you see it all the time in their
sculptures about 20 to 30 percent of
people have what is known as greek feet
[Music]
so-called egyptian feeds are when the
toes go down one by one in size in a
straight line
the egyptians were into their perfect
measurements
a so-called roman foot is where the toe
and the two toes next to it are roughly
the same length
good for walking and why are our feet so
ticklish and why does tickling make us
laugh
it's a mystery that's perplexed thinkers
from plato to galileo to darwin
the souls have a high concentration of
meissner's corpuscles
highly sensitive nerve receptors
scientists believe
these evolved as a defense mechanism to
protect vulnerable
areas of the body from injury it is also
thought that
tickling encourages social bonding
you can't tickle yourself
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video